a clouded sunrise over westminster
nothing extraordinary here many of
brexit's changes will be slow
banal even but in the minds of british
people
the uk now adrift from the eu is alone
again
for some that's a cause for optimism for
others
profound regret the country's still
working out what brexit means in
practice
with new rules on travel trade and
immigration to name a few
but beyond the dry details it's also
about something
much deeper for many brits especially
those in their twenties and thirties
being british and a member of the
european union
a part of one indivisible seamless
identity
that now as a result of brexit has been
split in two
of the 48 of people that voted to remain
in the european union
many now feel like they're being told to
abandon half
of who they are really sad to be
not european anymore i think it was a
really
awful decision that we made as a country
the idea that we're this nation in the
world that's
could do better outside of something the
size
of the european union i think is a bit
stupid it's hugely problematic
and the people who've grown up uh in the
80s 90s 90s a european identity was was
fundamental to how he saw the world we
got used to
being able to travel freely in the
european union being able to work there
live there and of course people who are
older were able to retire that
for others though european union
membership has felt in some way
forced and disingenuous voting to leave
the eu is a shock treatment for some
parts of the country
that felt left behind a way of restoring
the country's
factory settings i think it's a great
opportunity for the uk now to stand
alone and
to really build some business across the
world
but it's not as simple as hitting reset
in the past
fifty years the uk has become
intertwined with europe
london's often called france's sixth
biggest city because of its sizable
french population
unpicking the relationships required a
form of diplomatic surgery
in the shape of years of torturous
brexit negotiations
[Music]
the message for many of europe's leaders
is that brexit is not something to
celebrate
the last thing the eu wants is for the
first member state to ever leave the eu
to be followed by others how future
generations will judge this moment
we don't yet know is it the beginning of
new opportunities or the end of many
a sunrise or a sunset
neve barker al jazeera london